Super excellent , merci Akim
On est fier d'etre ici a Montréal pour soutenir l'équipe de France
Je peux vous dire qu'ici les gens sont a fond pour la finale
FAUX
Tout le monde s'en bat les c****illes
Mbappé !!! Tu m'entends ou pas !?!
La pression est totale pour voir le match,
- Attends, tu vas pas faire la moustache bleu/blanc /rouge quand même ?! -Si si si - Yes !
Super !!!
Ça c'est juste un porc qui a mal mangé une glace ! *Rires*
Bon, le match a déjà commencé,
On est toujours dans la voiture comme des c**s,
on est en train de se dire,
On s'en rappellera toute notre vie de ce moment
Et on se dira toute notre vie, pu***n c'était nul
Voilà, finalement on est là ! Très très tassés mais on voit le match !
We did it ! ( Nous l'avons fait )
Maintenant faut gagner.
LE BUT !!! Voilà, premier but pour la France !!!
J'adore ce bruit... vraiment !
Po, polo, po, po, po...(aller)
Là, ce qu'il faut voir, c'est ton projet sourcils !
AHHHH, j'avoue comment c'est moche comme ça !!!
Au moins t'es la seule à avoir fait ça... La seule et on comprend pourquoi !
Oh mon dieu! C'est un truc de ouf !
On est les champions, on est les champions...🎶
Bon, j'avais dit que l'ambiance était pas ouf à Montréal,
Bon... bah je me suis trompé hein !
C'est ça l'ambiance en fait !
CHAMPIONS DU MONDE !!!!
*ils chantent "I will survive"*
La, lala, la, la, lalalala
Et 4-2, Excellent, Super vive la France !
On vient de croiser Tania Dutel. La fameuse humoriste française.
Salut, salut les fans de Nono
*Rires*
Qu'est-ce que tu faisais toute seule ?
Heu, je me promenais pour trouver mes dernières tenues pour Netflix
Ha donc la meuf a incrusté sa promo dans le plan.           - Exactement ! * Rires *
Bonjour à tous ! On est à la Banquise. Apparemment c'est LE lieu pour manger une Poutine
La meilleure Poutine de Montréal, paraît-il.
Bon, moi c'est très simple, je vais prendre la classique. Car je suis un homme qui n'a pas de personnalité
Est-ce que vous savez que le perchman de cette vidéo est Pewdiepie.
Tu peux nous rejoindre ?
Nous sommes avec Pewdiepie   -Enchanté
Je suis avec une équipe de Baseball   - DE BALLE MOLLE ! De Balle Molle, voilà! Donc ça s’appelle Balle Molle. Parce que c'est pas tout à fait pareil...
C'est quoi en gros les règles de la Balle Molle ?
C'est exactement comme le baseball mais *incompréhensible* en bien
Je mettrais les sous titres par contre *Rires*
Je sens que je vais rater *Rires*
*Cris de victoire*
Thank you bro ! ( Merci les frères )
TABERNAK!!!
Un vrai "tabarnak" officiel celui là on l'a pas forcé, il est sorti tout seul.
*Rires*
Mon Dieu !
Wow !
Voilà de quoi nourrir ma famille pendant SIX MOIS!
C'est donc ça la fameuse poutine du Québec. Allez ! 3, 2, 1. Let's go ! (C'est parti !)
*Accent québecois* Mec, j'aime tellement ça, là.
Le québécois ? Mais moi j'adore mec, je suis vraiment fan de l'accent québécois.
Chaque fois on arrête pas de parler québécois. C'est pas qu'on se moque, c'est parce qu'on adore le faire, en fait.
Alors aujourd'hui, on est dans un endroit qui s'appelle "Les pique niques électroniques"
Un endroit où ça chill, où il y a beaucoup de musique électro
* voix de présentateur * Les teufeurs.. Leur drogue.. La musique électronique.
Danser toute la nuit sur des sons techno.
Mais qu'est-ce qui les motivent ?
Ja, ich mag das musik (Oui j'aime cette musique)
Ich mag electro musik (j'ai la musique electro)
Das ist Deutschland (c'est l'Allemagne)
P U B
Jack... Alain...
*accent québécois* Tu as tu magasiné dans de nouveaux endroits?
* Accent québécois* Tu trouves tu là? Ca n'a pas de bon sens là...
J'te niaise. C't'une joke. C't'une joke de papa.
En tout cas, ça sent crissement bon !
C'est normal! C'est " Crissement Bon " !
" Crissement Bon ", j'aime tellement ça là !
Depuis plus de trente ans, les teufeurs...
ne s’arrêtent plus de danser...
parcourant les festivals aux quatre coins du monde.
Ecoute, première impression, euh,
Wow, c'est des frites. Attends mais le fromage j'arrive pas à savoir ce que c'est...
Ca s’appelle le fromage squish squish.
Parce que quand tu mâche ça fait squish squish.
Franchement vous c'est tout simple, hein !
Y'a pas besoin de chercher midi à 14h.
Apparemment Clément t'es vraiment fan de pièces de monnaie, toi .
Je suis assez fan de pièces de monnaie, je vous la montre elle est juste là.
Attends regarde, elle peut devenir invisible pendant un court instant.
Là on voit plus rien mais là elle revient.
Eh, je regarderais au ralenti pour voir quel est le truc !
oh non!
Interdiction de remater ça, hein !
Je crois qu'il faut expliquer la base, donc t'es avec ton amie que tu as donc... attachée.
Tu te promène dans la rue comme ça ??
** accent québécois ** Ouais, c'est du BDSM en fait, c'est vraiment un kiff, qu'on se fait juste pour le plaisir
Et toi tu prends du plaisir ou pas ?
Oh oui, total !
T'es à quel pourcent de plaisir, là ?
A 100% de plaisir.
Et si tu veux te gratter le nez ou le visage ?
Ben c'est moi qui suis obligée de le faire.
Ah m*rde.Y a des avantages et des inconvénients.
Et bah tu sais quoi, bon kiff, bon bondage...
*Rires*
C'est comme ça qu'on dit hein ?
Ouais...
Bonjour, je suis un gladiateur.
Et non ! On est dans une salle de lancer de haches.
On va simplement lancer des haches extrêmement saillantes et violentes vers ces cibles.
A la manière de vrais barbares.
Est-ce que vous êtes prêts ? Moi j'ai juste hâte en fait !!
Parce que j'adore, en fait, être violent.... Allez c'est parti !
Fail
Voilà ! L'ennemi n'est pas tué..J'ai perdu
Et c'est technique ton truc ! *Rires *
Bouge d'un millimètre ton petit doigt!
Excuse moi, mais quand je regarde des films, JAMAIS le mec arrive comme ça...
*Applaudissement* YES !!
T'sais pourquoi c'est rouge ? C'est parce que je l'ai beaucoup mise dans le mille en fait !
Faux
Put*** !
*place la hache dans un trou et fait semblant d'avoir réussit*
Wesh c'est hyper dangereux imagine,
juste t'es comme as
*fait semblant de lacher la hache en arrière*
Ah excusez moi ! Yes, j'ai tué le mec. *Musique épique*
- Wow !  - Ouais donc j'te disais, moi à la base, c'est une spécialité en fait le lancer de hache.
Assasin's creed tu connais assasin's creed? -ouais- c'est plus une forme de tomahawk. tu connais les tomahawk?
- Comment ça s'appelle ça ? - Une hache ! *Rires génés*
J'pensais vraiment que c'était un, euh - Un stylo ! - Un stylo.
*Musique triste*
Je suis avec Michael qui est le gérant de la salle du lancer de hache
Il a carrément le tatouage de la hache sur le crâne quoi
T'as vraiment intérêt à le mettre dans le mille hein (Rires)
Hé Oussama ! D'après le règlement tu peux pas jeter une hache en tongs, c'est pas possible (Rires)
Ben voilà ! On a appris à lancer des haches. Je sais pas quand dans la vie ça peut te servir mais,
si un jour on me demande de  tuer un mec avec une hache j'pourrais faire : "Oui, je sais le faire"
Bon j'pense que ça se voit même à ma coupe de cheveux mais je suis malade
Qui est responsable ? Ceci, la climatisation.
Chaud, froid, chaud, froid, tu es malade
Comment bien NIQU** MES PUT*** DE VACANCES !!
Je suis chez le médecin ici, à Montréal et ici tout le monde porte un masque quand on consulte le médecin
J'ai l'impression que je suis un zombie infecté ou que je pue de la gueule
Les traductions de films par contre, vous êtes mauvais
Comme "Hangover", tu connais le film "Hangover"?            - Yeah Hangover ! (accent américain)
Il l'a appelé euh Very Bad Trip ! -Ouais ouais !
Vous euh c'est comment, c'est Fast and Furious, nous c'est Rapides et Dangereux. - Non! -Ouais. (Rires)
Hé mec on se mate rapides et dangereux 8 ?
*Musique indienne* - Des sonorités très très québécoises, merci Ahmed pour ce voyage en fait pour cette tranche de culture que tu nous offres.
- C'est quoi ce véhicule carrément culte ? -C'est un scooter électrique qui va à peu près à une vitesse de 30 km/h.
*Klaxon*
Wow ! Avec dérapage contrôlé mon pote ! (Rires)
Aujourd'hui à Montréal on est avec des gens qui font du GN donc du grandeur nature,
en gros ils se déguisent en personnages un peu heroic fantasy
et ils se battent pour de faux avec des armes qui ne tuent pas
Allons à leur rencontre ! des gobelins, des ogres, des orques, c'est parti !
Moi c'est Grum (?) On me surnomme " La chose"
Là , j'ai pas ma voix que j'utilise habituellement
*Prend une voix aigue * Parce que c'est comme ça
Norman: Et à quel moment on sait que le mec il est mort alors ?
Grum : ça va avec les points de vie T'as des points localisés: T'auras 2 points aux bras 3 points au torse
Euh si tu tues pas les 2 points au bras bah tu perds ton bras
Tu continues à te battre avec l'autre bras
Si tu perds tes points aux jambes , tu t'mets à terre
Norman: D'accord ...
Et genre ça arrive
qu'il y ait des gens qui tout d'un coup ils ... comment dire ?
Ils , ils lâchent le truc ils sont plus du tout euh RP
tu vois et du coup ils se mettent à parler normal et euh
La chose : oui ça on appelle ça "il est rendu ct'heure là!" (Il est déjà cet heure là!)
Norman : ça vous soûle ou euh
Grum : C'est pas le fait que ça nous soûle c'est que on est entre amis pis entres amis
Quand on est sur le bar autour d'une bière
Mais là on pense sur les vidéos qu'on a vues sur Youtube
Hein c'est quoi ça Youtube?
*Rires de Norman* c'est drôle ça
Grum : non non mais même le téléphone
y'en a qui appellent ça une tablette magique
Norman: Donc ça on dirait pas comme ça à la caméra mais c'est trés
trés mou, aucune douleur
Autre joueur (malak) : Sinon moi
mon personnage, celui que je jouerai en ce moment
ça serait plutôt un humain, malak (?)
C'est un fou, un peu
Une règle ça serait de mettre mon poing
en l'air pour dire que je suis transparent et puis
"le monde ne me voit pas"
Norman: Donc si jamais tu te mets en position "fufu"
Et que le gars qui joue avec toi est censé savoir
Il doit faire "put**..
... Mais y'a personne ici je comprends pas!"
Il doit faire comme ça?
Malak : Oui exactement
*Rires puis musique*
Je vous duel ! Attends, je vais.. Non mais d'abord battez-vous
Moi je vais.., je vais me faire un MacDo, j'arrive
*musique épique*
Norman : Bon t'as perdu en gros là
Grum : ouais
Norman : on vas pas se mentire hein
bah attend je prend quel arme alors là
Malak : c'que tu veux
Norman : bah attend euh
donne moi une arme quand même assez puissante quand même
OK! Je suis Hight-Lander
*re musique épique*
AH mon dos! je dois continuer la bataille!
*beaucoup de argh et de shlink*
Merci a tous!
norman : bah écoute j'te remercie
Grum : j'ai plu mon masque là mais de rien, de rien ça fait plaisir
Norman : c'est un p'tit bonnheur
merci bro
Malak : Salut
*coup COMPLETEMENT gratuit*
Norman : c'est comme ça qu'on dit au revoir en faite dans ce milieu
Ciao!
Silvain il m'a dit: "avant de partir je te laisse
"Avant de partir je te laisse ceci. C'est les couilles de Grum." (?)
C'est à dire les couilles de son personnage.
C'est la première fois qu'on m'offre des couilles en fait.
Putain mec je vais jamais réussir à finir ça
C'est... C'est beaucoup trop !
Ca manquait de sauce un petit peu !
Donc on rajoute du Ketchup. Vous avez pas du sucre en poudre ?
(???) il a fait : "Moi c'est pas assez, j'vais plutôt prendre un petit peu de crème en plus".
Hein, j'espère qu'il y a des toilettes à proximité !
Mec, je suis en vacances, juste, je déconnecte. Il n'y a plus de euh.. Fortnite, de.. on joue aux jeux vidéos, y'a plus, c'est... ça c'est en France ça !
Attends attends, vite fait ça ! Je fais juste une partie !
-Et ça ?
-Ca te va pas du tout mec, pas du tout !
Alors, y'a Akim et Ahmed qui m'ont provoqués en disant qu'ils étaient sans doute meilleurs que moi au ping pong.
Alors directement j'suis allé au magasin de sport, et j'ai acheté ceci.
On se rappelle ce fabuleux match contre Cyril Hanouna, que j'ai perdu.. en 8 secondes.
Extrait du match de ping pong "Cyril Hanouna VS Norman"
Alors euh.. si jamais je gagne, tu mets un post insta(gram) où tu dis "Ce mec.. j'me suis vraiment inspiré de lui depuis le début... et c'est grace à lui que j'suis là".
*rires*
Si je gagne, tu dois commencer tes vidéos youtube par "Excellent, super"
-Oh Putain..
Et terminer, et terminer chaque vidéo par "(j'ai pas compris)"
-C'est parti !
-Messieurs dames, le pari est tenu !
*Musique*
(putain ta mère)
(pas compris)
(mais attends, mais le soleil !)
*Musique*
Putain ! *musique dramatique*
-C'est vraiment la chance du débutant quand même..
-Ok, Cyril Hanouna c'est fait, Akim c'est fait..
Donc ça va, j'me fais bien humilier.
-J'te laisse expliquer...
-Bah les gars..Petite victoire ! De moi ! C'est lui qui va devoir faire euh... le petit gage !
Donc euh.. cette vidéo vous allez voir comment elle va commencer... Super !
*rires*
*voix romantique*
Salut..Tu veux un verre ?
On dirait pas une musique de gros film de cul? (la musique est comme celle d'un film de cul)
*rire*
Et pourtant.. il s'agit de mario tennis !
*rires*
*IL PARLE LA BOUCHE PLEINE DONC JE COMPREND PAS*
*applaudissements*
Bon bah j'ai perdu mon défi !
On a testé la poutine québécoise, ça, c'est fait !
Là, en l'occurence, *incompréhensible* tabarnak
On a putain de bien mangé
-Vous avez BEAUCOUP mangé
Ouais là j'ai carrément mangé en tabarnak en fait ! Et vous vous avez déjà mangé en tabarnak?
Dites le nous dans les commentaires !
Bon, y'a un poto qui est venu me voir..
Je pense que tu peux redire ce que tu m'a dit ;
Ouais, moi c'est Merlin, et en fait euh vu que c'est le nom de ton chat, j'me suis dit pourquoi pas kiffer
J'penserais à Wat (?) quand je caresserais mon chat.
Pire phrase du monde ! *rires* Très bizarre !
Donc c'est quoi ton expression euh..culte québécoise ?
"On peut s'enfarger dans les fleurs du tapis"
Ca veut dire..on doit pas s'embarrasser des détails.
Oh, woah, mec merci. En fait t'es un peu le Bernard Pivot.. euh.. du Québec
*rires*
Pourquoi dès que je fais un vlog à l'étranger.. les conditions météorologiques.. sont catastrophiques ?
*extrait d'une autre vidéo*
Ca, c'est les Bahamas ?! Wouh !
A chaque fois j'hallucine des souvenirs qu'ils proposent... tu vois un pote et tu fais "Mec, bah tiens un frisbee en fait du Canada, j'espère que tu pourras en faire bon usage"
Le chapeau que personne ne portera dans sa vie une seule fois
Le cadeau pour les gens.. de 90 ans !
N'empêche tu vois, cet objet, avant qu'il soit utilisé, on peut vraiment le malaxer.. c'est pas sale !
*dialogues ininteressants*
Tu vois, même quand j'fais ça, y'a aucun problème en fait ("Ah" en fond), c'est après que c'est sale !
*rires*
On dirait qu'on a un rendez-vous dans GTA, là. Un petit deal de drogue
Aujourd'hui on va faire du hockey sur glace
est-ce que vous êtes prêts?
*"Ouaiiis" collectif*
Okay, c'est parti, donc quand on fait du hockey sur glace on se protège parce qu'on va se faire péter la gueule !
(tout simplement)
Ah, là je sens bien mes c***lles bien moulées
Alors c'est super stylé avant, mais une fois que t'es dans la glace t'es un gros con, c'est sûr
Yes, tu.. fais ton projet
*rires de fond*
J'ai le sentiment de me faire coller de ciment là
*on entend trois gros coup sur le dos de Norman*
Yes !
*l'accent québécois est très fort donc on ne comprend pas mais c'est une tactique pour gagner*
C'est clair ou c'est pas clair ?!!
Oui.. oui
Le grand moment est arrivé !
Woh putain, ça glisse beaucoup !
C'est peut-être mon premier but du hockey !
C'est maintenant !
J'm'en souviendrais toute ma vie !
et j'vais le faire !
OUI !
I did it !
Bien joué ! Bien joué !
Ca va très très vite sur la glace.
En fait je sens qu'à tout moment si je fais une chute, elle peut être extrêmement violente.
Et du coup tu stresses un peu ! Je suis en train de suer comme un porc
dans ma combinaison, mais comme elle passe de mec en mec, on se mélange un peu nos sueurs, hein
C'est un vrai plaisir.
*l'accent québécois est trop fort mais il lui donne des conseils*
Ca marche pas la technique euh..freinage de Roller Toysrus
Ohhh !
On fait moins le malin !
Merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, merci à tous les potos de nous avoir accueillis
les mecs nous ont très bien reçus
et j'espère qu'on va revenir prochainement parce que ce pays est.. est unique
Ciao !
Ouais je rentre chez oim ! (moi)
*incompréhensible*
*Musique d'outro*
Enfin fini, j'espère que ça sera utile à des gens ces sous-titres !